what up guys welcome to the Jazz pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and and you
already know guys yesterday I went to a
feminist event okay I went to a feminist
event and I wore my women shouldn't vote
t-shirt needless to say I was greeted
with a lot of warmth
loving amazing welcome they all just
said Pearl you're so awesome and amazing
um so tune into the footage that should
be dropped later this week and get
yourself a woman shouldn't vote t-shirt
today the link is in the description
guys I'm telling you they love the
shirts women will just come up to you
left and right and today's theme is
really going to talk about how when
women make decisions typically they find
someone else to Blink whoever is like
the closest person to blame I don't know
why we're like this it's just we just
tend to do it so Lana Rhodes is an
ex-porn star and I guess a couple of
years ago this girl was really big on
the porn sites I think she's got some
other videos out there I don't I don't
really know not my thing
um but it's interesting to see like what
path her life has gone down because you
know she was the hottest thing in porn I
guess I think she did it for a year and
then she transitioned into social media
which is a really common like path that
I see a lot of these like porn stars
make
and it's really interesting because
you know she there's clips of her that
go viral about her regretting porn but
she still kind of chooses to be a public
figure and use her porn name
so that's a little bit confusing to me
but there is a clip of her going viral
um talking about her regrets in the porn
industry pull it up they say smart
people learn from other people's
mistakes schools learn from their own is
very much a fool in most of my decisions
even with all the success that you've
had your incredible mother now business
woman you're working with Playboy you
still look back on that and you still
feel ashamed yeah I don't like the fact
that people can see me naked on the
Internet or I can see those things
happening to me I think that it's gross
that is crazy that you can can build
this whole life and you still feel
ashamed I mean I'm I'm proud of myself
and what I've done and and I wouldn't
take anything back however it's not like
I love I like the idea that people can
view that of me I personally those
videos make me want to throw up okay a
couple things why don't porn stars just
admit they would take it back
I mean hell I think everyone can look
back at their lives and think of a
couple things that we could take back I
just I get so confused as to like why we
don't just say yeah I would take it back
so a couple things I am I do appreciate
that she's being honest because a lot of
porn stars are not honest about the
consequences of their actions and they
kind of act like there's no consequences
you can go into porn and you'll just
have a happy life after and it's really
just not the case you know
she's a successful businesswoman but
would she be a successful businesswoman
without porn getting her to be well
known I have a hard time believing it
and it's interesting to say she's
learned from her mistakes she kind of
went on this like hoe we call it like
the whole apology tour
um which is fine right at least they're
being honest but you know it just makes
me question then you go and get pregnant
by an NBA player allegedly
are your single mom it's kind of like
that's why men I'm telling you guys this
is why men really don't uh believe women
when we do these apology tours because a
lot of times and then you'll you'll see
like Mia Khalifa did the whole apology
tour then she started only fans again
and they always seem to blame it on like
the predatory men rather than their
desire for attention you know and and I
I've yet to really see a porn star take
accountability and say yeah I just
wanted more and more attention and I
would do anything to get it and I now
I'm paying the price it's always well I
was coerced I was
coaxed I was abused whatever